In other words, if you increase
the size of your outputs,
your classifier becomes very
confident about its predictions.
But if you reduce
the size of your outputs,
your classifier becomes very unsure.
Keep this in mind for later.
We'll want our classifier to not be
too sure of itself in the beginning.
And then over time,
it will gain confidence as it learns.
Next, we need a way to represent
our labels mathematically.
We just said, let's have the
probabilities for the correct class be
close to 1, and the probability for
all the others be close to 0.
We can write exactly with that.
Each label will be
represented by a vector
that is as long as there are classes and
it has the value 1.0 for the correct
class and 0 every where else.
This is often called one-hot encoding.